hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about future of Science
and Technology and I see all kinds of
interesting questions
uh that have been submitted here so let
me uh tackle try to tackle a few of
these
let me see
uh lolola asks do you think houses are
going to change much in the future will
we reach the age of age of true smart
houses
you know the house that by the way now
we built 22 years ago maybe
and uh
at that time there were all these things
about you know make your house how smart
you know put in all of these different
kinds of things in the end
uh the big decision we made was to run
empty conduit in walls so that whatever
new fiber optic you know this side or
the other thing might come out in the
future would be usable and that that was
uh fairly useful I wouldn't say it's
dramatically useful as an awful lot of
conduit that's never been used
but um uh you know at that time 22 years
ago there was a lot of enthusiasm for
you know all these things that would
make your house uh sort of
um you know smart for you all the uh you
know we put in all kinds of uh uh
automated light switch type things and
so on
um I have to say if I were to rank
things that have affected my quality of
life those were definitely not big
positives so to speak
um and more of a uh sort of user
experience pen in the neck now you know
over that period of time things like you
know smart thermostats those are a thing
uh all kinds of
um uh you know talk to your house type
things those have come into existence
and and I guess work okay I don't use
them myself
um you know what about houses should be
smart it is another thing to realize if
you look at houses that were built you
know hundreds of years ago and you say
uh you know they were very simple that
they just had walls and maybe they had
windows and so on a house today has all
kinds of crud in its walls and all kinds
of you know all kinds of ducts for air
conditioning all kinds of electrical
cables probably network cables unless
it's all Wireless
um etc etc et cetera somehow there's a
complexity to building houses that seems
to stay sort of constant over time that
even though things get more automated
and Etc et cetera et cetera there's just
more things that are expected of houses
and then people occasionally try and do
very different things in the
construction of houses like don't have
square rooms you know put all kinds of
other exotic things in mostly those have
not been a big success partly because
people need I think to be an
architecture that they feel comfortable
in and when it gets too weird and too
different from what's been seen before
possibly too different from what people
kind of experience in the natural world
it isn't something that plays well for
people
so I mean I guess the question would be
what uh you know they're things that
people have said would happen for a long
time like for example make all of your
walls be displays you know just have uh
don't um I remember from a long time ago
um
uh I think I told the story before my
wife always gives me a hard time in
terms of future prediction that this was
probably beginning of the 1990s uh
renovating some some house and it's like
how deep do you have to make a niche to
fit a television in and I was like look
four inches is going to be fine because
that was what was happened to be
available in that particular
configuration because I'd already seen
Smart TV uh flat flat screen televisions
but it turns out it took another decade
for flat screen televisions to become
common basically because the yield of
making things with those kinds of
display elements was not enough and you
can really tell if there's a display
element that isn't working somewhere in
a television so you have to get the
yield up to the point where basically
every pixel works but you know this has
been a a long time thing oh we'll have
kind of uh sort of soft walls so to
speak by by Soft I mean soft in the
sense of software where you can sort of
put anything on the walls so to speak
and I suppose you know there have been a
bunch of attempts to make sort of soft
this and the other things another one
that was a thing for a little while was
soft keyboards where all he would have
would just be essentially a display in
the position of the keys for the
keyboard and you know when you press the
shift key you get Greek keys or
mathematical keys or something like this
I think I have somewhere a computer that
was uh that had that kind of capability
didn't work very well
you know one month says such and such a
thing didn't work very well one of the
features of Technology tends to be that
sometimes it comes back sometimes it
didn't work well because there wasn't
the right kind of force feedback feeling
of touching the keys and so on and then
there'll be a new technology that makes
that work and then that idea will come
back I mean there have been plenty of
ideas that would sort of try decades
before that time it kind of didn't work
and then things developed better and
then they kind of came back and really
worked the next time around so you know
maybe I shouldn't be saying that about
uh uh kind of some of these aspects of
um uh of sort of smart houses but I mean
in terms of other kinds of things there
are lots of things people talk about
another one is Electro optic uh Windows
um you know it's like I think the 787
has these where you know you just touch
a button and it's using uh Electro
Optics to you know change the
polarization of uh the the the
polarizing effects of the material and
be able to make everything dark so
instead of you know no more uh you know
no more screens just um uh you know no
more blinds for Windows just you know
press the button again a lot of these
things you know right now that will be
too expensive to do uh in any large
scale and um uh you know again that
that's the kind of thing that might
might come in time you know other kinds
of things there's also all of the home
robot stuff
um and uh you know I see companies see
many companies over the course of the
last few decades that have have talked
about various kinds of sort of Home
robot capabilities
um you know the the the the vacuum
cleaner thing that worked that was 20
years ago or something that started to
work and uh uh it's um
uh but you know more more General I I
remember a few years ago at the Consumer
Electronics Show seeing the uh a laundry
you know folding robot huge lines to see
it people thought this was really cool
whether that's a real thing I don't know
yet
um you know eventually some of those
kinds of things that require physically
moving stuff around
um uh will be roboticizable although
those are comparatively difficult they
require things like you know robots to
grab things robots to pick things up
that turns out to be a very hard problem
mixture of machine learning and uh
actuation and planning and so on that
turns out to be really hard and you know
notably when you see things like
automated Labs where lots and lots of
stuff has been automated they move the
sample from here to there is still
typically done by a person because
that's just it's there's there's much
else that can be automated but but
that's one of the more difficult things
to automate
so I'm I'm
I'm trying to think what other vectors
of automation are there for for houses
um I think uh you know what does one
want from one's house so to speak I
suppose the um uh you know this kind of
um you know control the lights control
sound
uh you know put things away you know I I
think I don't know what the effect of uh
augmented reality you know widespread of
Adventure reality would be on on house
Behavior so to speak I mean one of the
things I've thought about for ages is
visual diffs so you know you kind of you
come into a room what's out of place you
know what what do you want to put back
you know if I've got books that I pulled
out of my bookshelves and I want to put
them back in the same order well if I
had some augmented reality system that
I'm wearing it can just say oh you've
got this book in your hand great you
know I know exactly where that goes and
I can put it back or it can give you a
diff of how your bookshelves are
different from what they were before
um but I don't know you know that
doesn't uh uh I don't know whether the
sort of average degree of of
declutteredness of houses might change
as a result of those things I'm not
really sure I mean another thing I
suppose that is um is various kinds of
uh you know the air tags or other tags
like that and how routinely those are
put on things
um I mean that's a uh that's a thing
that one still doesn't you know that's
people use them a bit but they're not
sort of uh widely used I suppose again
like the visual diffs thing one imagine
it's like you know just have uh this
this camera that's uh that's watching
the room and just notices oh this is out
of place that's how to play so that's
where you put such and such a thing I
can see it it's in such and such a run
so
uh
let's see other things people are asking
here
um
okay David is asking here in the next 20
years will artificial intelligent image
recognition and image segmentation equal
the accuracy of human experts for
example with AI Pathologists or
Radiologists uh will they get to the
point of of being like human
Pathologists or Radiologists you know I
asked that question regularly when I run
into people who are in those fields and
um my impression is that for example in
Radiology which seems like the place
where there is the most immediate kind
of AI assistance potentially available
what's happened and it's happened over
the course of many years not just in the
in the current uh phase of AI
is there's a lot of AI assistance you
know your average ultrasound you can you
know highlight it it automatically tries
to highlight organs and show
measurements and things like this
um the uh I think that there's a a
degree of kind of oh you can find this
or that kind of thing automatically
that's happened it is also the case that
it's still
this I don't know there's still an awful
lot of sort of weird anatomy and I
suppose I suppose one of the questions
is
um what are you trying to compute in
Radiology for example you know if you do
Radiology of anybody you'll find all
kinds of weird things that are different
from the average person
um and uh you know it and the question
is okay you can you can flag that you
can say this is a thing we expected
might be weird and now we notice that
it's weird you know it's a cyst
somewhere it's a it's a thing where the
you know blood flow is different it's a
thing where something is is different or
whatever let's flag that and that's a
thing we know has a diagnosis of some
kind so I can imagine that the kind of
teach the AI to the diagnosis is a thing
that can be done and you know and has
been done a lot of cases of saying if
you're looking for a this kind of thing
then uh you know then this is what that
then then the AI will find it you know
it's a thing I've noticed when you see
particularly kids who say oh I've done
some machine learning uh uh training
program or something and we did this
project and it's like what's the project
it's you know brain tumors and lung lung
cancers are like seem like that's the
project you always hear about it's like
well we looked at those and and you know
I think what's true is that that there
is a certain level of of looking for
sort of obvious things where you kind of
know the diagnosis you know what you're
looking for that is very AI accessible
when it gets more funky I think it's
much harder and it's kind of like what's
the thing trying to figure out if the
thing's trying to figure out you know do
you have diagnosis X
that I think is more more has more
potential than if the question is you
know will this thing turn out to uh you
know grow more or do this or that or the
other that is less well defined I think
that's more difficult you know what I've
heard is that in pathology for example
there are again there's a lot of
computer assistance that's possible but
there's still plenty of things that have
not been been dealt with partly because
again there's there's sort of too much
diversity in what can happen I think it
also matters in um
well I I mean that's that's my
impression now what's the rate of
improvement and uh at what point does
one sort of say okay the AIS have it one
of the things that's been notable about
machine learning is it has this habit of
you know there's sort of a breakthrough
like deep learning from for image
processing which was a 2011 kind of time
frame breakthrough there's sort of a
breakthrough there's a big jump in
capability and then it goes very
gradually and one of the things that
tends to happen is there's a certain
error rate and it's hard to get that
error rate down and so if it's like a
screening thing where you say well you
know 80 I want to know is it uh you know
if I if 80 chance of getting it right is
useful then the machine learning can do
a good job if you really care about that
99th percentile or something then it's
really hard to make that work and so I
think it's another question is in these
medical situations are there cases where
having kind of the 80 screen is useful
or is it really that you want the 99
certainty and I think that you know
those different use cases can have
different consequences there but you
know in in terms of does one see in the
case of uh sort of typical sort of AI
based systems does one see kind of a
very Progressive kind of Moore's Law
like like Improvement curve my
impression is not really now I remember
remember when Wilson Alpha came out in
2009 we had a very straightforward test
for how well we were doing which is how
many what we call fall throughs occurred
how many things people typed in we
couldn't deal with
two things happened
one was we managed to analyze those four
throughs and make them work better and
the second was the humans who were using
Wolfram Alpha learned the kinds of
things that would plausibly work and
ones which wouldn't
between both of those things over the
course of about three or four years we
saw kind of a almost sort of we saw kind
of an exponential Improvement
up to very high success rate for many
kinds of things
um and that was but I'm afraid that that
was a combination of our sort of
technical prowess and improving things
and the use case change of people seeing
what would work and what wouldn't and I
think that's also true with some of
these you know things like medical Ai
and so on where it's like here's the
thing that's actually going to work
let's really push on it versus you know
what the AI is just not managing do a
very good job of this you know let's
let's work it differently in that in
that particular area
let's see
uh
okay Sal asks how long do you estimate
before AI can do creative mathematics
how will this technology be similar or
different than GPT
well you see the thing is it's very easy
for a computer to be creative in
mathematics the problem is it can be so
creative that humans don't care about
what it's producing it's very easy to go
out and have an automated theorem
proving system a proof assistant type
system that's been automated uh go and
just start enumerating true theorems of
mathematics you just say here are some
axioms let's go apply these actions in
different ways great we've got a new
true theorem in fact I even wrote this
book about the physicalization of matter
mathematics where I'm talking about the
kind of infinite limit of mathematics
where you're kind of looking at proving
all possible theorems of mathematics you
get this giant entailment graph of
possible theorems of mathematics
here's the bug the bug with that is yes
you can prove all these theorems but the
question is which ones are human
mathematicians are going to say oh
that's really interesting we care about
that one versus like oh that's just
another theorem that happens to be true
from these actions and we don't care so
in a sense the challenge is how do you
find the quotes interesting theorems and
what tends to happen in the development
of mathematics is that one builds these
kinds of towers of interestingness and
those are partly built in a social way
it's partly like you know there could be
a mathematician out there who builds a
giant Tower and nobody else cares about
it just like there could be a person who
invents a language which only they they
only speak to themselves and that is a
thing that is of a different character
than a thing that is a language that's
used to communicate ideas from one
person to another so to speak so I think
it's it's uh this question about sort of
uh how do you build towers of
mathematics that are creative that's
easy you just go enumerate arbitrary
theorems you go explore the
computational universe of possible
things that are true what's more
difficult is identifying which ones
humans are going to say are high care
about that now you could imagine having
you go a little distance away from what
humans already know they're about three
or four million theorems that humans
have published in the literature of
mathematics you can think of that as
kind of a front of where mathematics is
reached actually more accurately you can
probably think about it this way there's
the space of all possible theorems and
that is a space that has many
interesting characteristics that's what
my book about physicalization and
Mathematics is really about is about the
structure of the space of all possible
mathematical theorems but in that space
there's sort of certain places that have
been colonized so it's kind of like
physical space you know we got the
surface of the Earth it's this whole
physical area laid out in you know space
on the surface of the sphere more or
less but now there are particular places
where people built cities and where
people live and where people care about
that place on the surface of the Earth
and in uh you know there are really
weird places on the surface of the Earth
like for example there's null Island you
know the the equator uh
um you know intersects the Greenwich
Meridian the the uh zero zero of
longitude latitude where it's just
someplace out in the Atlantic Ocean and
sort of nobody really cares about it
except for the fact that it's kind of an
amusing kind of place that sort of the
default for a geo location system that
knows nothing will say oh you're at zero
zero that's null Island I mean I'm sure
one day somebody will build a null
Island thing at Nile Island just for the
sake of there being something there a
sort of a tourist attraction of some
kind but uh what I'm saying is that the
you know what's relevant on the surface
of the Earth is the places that have
been populated with cities and so on in
meta mathematical space it's sort of the
same idea there's this big space of
possible mathematics and they're these
places that have been sort of populated
by humans where humans have chosen and
human mathematicians have chosen to sort
of live in those places and so this
question about how do you extend out
from where we've already colonized to
sort of colonize further in mathematic
mathematical space is an interesting
question I think that there is a
possibility of using llm-like technology
to say oh here are the things that we
already cared about in mathematics is
three or four million theorems that
humans already cared about use the
pattern of those theorems to say which
of the possible theorems that we can get
to from uh from the axioms that we
choose to believe in which of those
possible theorems are ones that we're
likely to care about based on our
pattern of caring about things it's like
saying we're going to generate sentences
with an llm for example and those
sentences might be you know tell the llm
go generate a haiku or something and
it's going to generate some small number
of words and the question is are those
words that we're going to care about or
not and they you know it could be that
they're syntactically correct but
they're ones where we just sort of shrug
and we say yeah okay you could say that
but who cares I mean I suppose the same
thing happens as well with music you
know it's sort of a combinatorial thing
you can just put together notes and you
can put together any sequence of notes
but many of those sequences of notes
people just say that sounds terrible or
they'll just say oh I don't know what
that's about you know and they're still
shrug about it what is relevant is the
things that for some reason or another
resonate with us humans and that
resonance with us is I think in large
part related to the things that we are
already familiar with that is we get to
sort of build out from what we already
know in mathematics in the language that
we use in music for example and perhaps
there's some intrinsic kind of uh uh
characteristics that we humans have that
make things make sense to us there are
things I suspect that are associated
with kind of the the computational
characteristics of brains that are
things where we're going to be able to
understand that versus we're not really
going to be able to understand that
there are things in mathematics where we
get to sort of see it we have a certain
way of sampling mathematical space we
have a certain way in in natural human
language of kind of knowing what is uh
for example reasonable for us to deal
with for example very very simple
example if if the llm was generating
lovely sentences which said the cat
which did this which did this which did
this which did this which did this and
so on very very deeply nested we mostly
won't get it we'll just sort of say oh
we lost it I don't know what that was
about
so it's not it's not a well it doesn't
have a good sort of human connection to
us
it's not that that's not the best of
examples because that's a more sort of
mechanical problem so to speak but it's
also just you know you can write an
essay and it's like that was just
completely banal and vapid and it didn't
really say anything and you just shrug
your shoulders and it's like it's got a
bunch of words but it didn't really say
anything and that's something where you
could have that be sort of the output of
the llm or you can have the llm produce
something where you look at it and you
say well that's really interesting type
thing and so it is with mathematics
so I think that's that's really the the
challenge this challenge of of being
able to detect interestingness and
that's a uh you know there's a sort of
another analogy there in art
you know when in times past you know art
was like I've got a I've got a scene in
front of me photographs didn't exist I
want to be able to represent that scene
in some way that's somehow faithful and
reminds me of that scene and then we get
to more sort of deconstructed Modern Art
where it's like well there's this thing
and it's a bunch of paint on a canvas
and you know in many cases you just
shrug and it's like I don't know what
this is about you know it's just a bunch
of random splatters of paint I don't
know what this is but if there's a sort
of a chain of kind of uh Human
Experience that says oh yes that's a
thing one recognizes that that has this
meaning to us that resonates in this way
because we've kind of have understood it
it's kind of defined just like in in a
language we might say over time we
introduce new words into the language
and then people get to talk in terms of
those words those words develop kind of
a meaning for through their use so
similarly one can say that sort of these
various artistic forms develop a meaning
through familiarity and so on that then
allows them to kind of have more human
connection
so I think that's that's uh that's
that's what I would say that that um
uh the challenge with AI is not to do
the mathematics the challenge is to see
whether humans will care about it
let's see zanya asks do you think
smartphones will replace desktop
computing
uh
I don't know I think that the
I mean I'm just amazed when it comes to
particularly younger people but not only
younger people uh the things they're
prepared to do on their phone I mean
it's tiny and it's very inconvenient to
type on and voice is only good for
certain kinds of things and voice is
only good in certain kinds of situations
and I think that for me it's uh you know
I have I have screens of pretty much all
sizes and there are definitely tasks for
which using multiple big screens is very
very useful there are other tasks for
which a standard laptop screen will work
there are other tasks for which a phone
screen will work
um I would say that there's a sort of
hierarchy of tasks and I don't think
it's just a question of bad ux so to
speak I don't think it's the case that
if there was a better ux for let's say
programming on a phone then I would say
oh yeah I'm going to program on my phone
I think it really is something where you
know we humans have certain scaling to
our to ourselves you know we have those
you know we have fingers that are a
certain size that we can use to type on
things we have eyes that have a certain
resolution and a certain uh angular
um sort of um what is it called sort of
angular range
um and uh if we
and those are the things that we
potentially can make use of in doing
sort of sophisticated let's say things
where you need a lot of different inputs
to be able to to do what you're doing so
to speak like in certain kinds of
programming kinds of tasks and so on or
certain kinds of research tasks where
you've got many many windows up on the
screen you're looking at lots of
different things and so on and you're
trying to sort of correlate lots of
things together I don't think that's
doable really on a phone and I think
that's a matter of the way we humans are
set up we're just we have this big sort
of opening angle of of things we can see
we have 10 million fibers in our optic
nerves we have a certain you know
ability to see a certain resolution and
the phone is not a great way to to sort
of plug into all of that resolution
I think it'll be interesting to see what
happens with the next generation of
virtual reality systems and so on Whose
main function I think will be yet
another form factor of screen so you
know I fully expect that with high
resolution virtual reality one will be
able to have yeah you know those eight
screens arranged all over one's visual
field in a convenient way and I suspect
for some tasks it will be kind of rather
uh impressive that one will be able to
just make use of all these things really
as the most direct sort of path into
one's brain one can get it's kind of
like forget direct brain connection
we're going to use all those 10 million
fibers and our optic nerves and so on
from this sort of fully uh fully worked
out virtual reality so I have to say I
think um
um
and uh I'm I'm I expect that there are
uses for screens of all sizes so to
speak from the watch size to the phone
size to the tablet size to the laptop
size to the desktop to the big you know
multi-screen desktop to the virtual
reality cover everything to the wall
size screen I think these all have
certain uh you know uses I mean it's
kind of like
there are things in our world of
different sizes you know a chair is a
certain size because gosh we're a
certain size and we want to sit on it
um and you know something else which is
uh you know a thing that is uh you know
a watch is of a certain size because we
want to wear it on our wrist so you know
I think we provide certain scales and
our displays and so on need to match
those kinds of scales and the thing
that's interesting is that there are
multiple scales of display that uh that
makes sense so to speak and I think that
will continue to be the case
uh
let's see
um
Muhammad asks does it make sense to
pursue a math degree in the age of AI
heck yes
uh the the thing is math has been
practiced in a certain way
uh where sort of well in my own efforts
over the last 35 years we've been able
to add sort of a computer assist to the
doing of math and that's allowed a lot
more math to get done a lot of things
that have been discovered in the last 35
years have relied in one way or another
on the math that could be done using
Mathematica and using you know using
computation actually I think vastly less
of that has been done than could be done
because math as a sort of cultural
tradition has really been about kind of
let's prove a theorem let's do this
let's let's rather than let's go out and
explore the world of experimental
mathematics which computers are really
good at doing and uh just discover what
might be true and then try and build a
theory from which we can make proofs or
whatever else we want to do you know
doing experimental math is a thing that
requires skill it's you can do it badly
as you can do most things badly doing
experimental mathematics well is a story
it's a bit like doing physical
experiments well you have to make a very
clean experiment you have to know what
the experiment is about you have to not
have oh you know I don't really know why
that Mouse died maybe it died because
something that was irrelevant you know
independent of the of the weird
monoclonal antibody I gave it you know
maybe it died because it had rat poison
or something that was completely
independent of that you you want to make
an experiment that is as you know on
point as possible that deals with just
what you're talking about and nothing
more that is a simple kind of
well-defined experiment and that that
affects mathematical experiments as it
affects experiments in physics biology
whatever else and I would say that the
the number of people who've learned how
to do mathematical experiments is still
way fewer than it should be I mean mean
a bunch of careers have been built with
that I'm happy to say I've sometimes
you know LED people in the direction of
doing those kinds of things
um and and they've worked out you know
extremely well it's worth remembering
that in the history of mathematics some
of the great mathematicians that
everybody's heard of like Gauss or
ramanujan uh the the the seed of things
that they studied was often experimental
mathematics for for ramanujan it kind of
almost stayed that way that was the the
main story but for Gauss you know oh I'm
gonna just count up a bunch of primes
and see what their actual distribution
is okay let me try and make a theorem
about the fact that that the following
is true about the distribution of primes
but it starts with an experiment now one
of the things that's been true about
experimental mathematics
is that many of the experiments one can
do computationally are experiments where
ordinary mathematical theorem proving
just can't get there you can you
discover things where there's
undecidability where there's
computational irreducibility where kind
of the standard methods of mathematics
which are very kind of um I would say
very sort of human in their
characteristics can't really reach it
the only way you can find out what's
true is to run the experiment and see
what happens you can't have a narrative
that sort of fits in the human mind that
talks about how it works so that's been
one of the characteristics of
mathematics as opposed to the arbitrary
computational universe is things where
the explanation kind of fits in a human
mind things where you can build that
tower that I was talking about earlier
and you can sort of go up the tower
always kind of following a human
narrative so to speak rather than just
saying and now you have to do lots of
computation but I would say that
mathematics is uh a um an area you know
what does one get out of learning
mathematics
at a kind of uh
at a very Elementary level so there's
mathematics that's relevant for just
basic existence in the world and
commerce and things like this but um
beyond that uh the you know I think
there's a certain amount of mathematics
that where people have been sort of
teaching the machinery for hundreds of
years and that Machinery does not need
to be taught anymore just like you know
I never learned to take a feather and
turn it into a quill pen just not a very
useful Thing by the time I was around
you know well there were there were just
the ballpoint pens weren't as common as
as they are ubiquitous today and it was
more like it was fountain pens and you
actually had to put ink in them and
things but you definitely didn't have to
make your fountain pen from a feather
type thing that was a lost art and so
similarly you know taking a square root
by hand
should is a lost art and should be a
last start because it's just not
something people need to do anymore and
I think there are lots of mechanical
aspects of mathematics that you know in
my own efforts have been significant I
suppose in making this happen those have
been automated we can we can kind of
zero out the effort needed to do that
but now we get to go a lot further in
mathematics we get to go a lot further
in understanding concepts in mathematics
we get to go a lot further in what we
can discover and do in mathematics and
the ways we can use mathematics but in
terms of what people learn when they
learn mathematics there's a lot of
interesting abstract structure that
exists in particularly higher
mathematics and um it's uh you know it's
it's ways of kind of taking the world
and making it kind of stuff again in
human brains you know the idea of I
don't know the curvature of a surface or
something the idea of curvature it's a
general idea once you you have that idea
you can apply it to lots of things it's
an idea that sort of is understandable
to a human once you've sort of got there
once you've learned the math around it
or the idea of derivatives or something
like that the idea of a derivative once
you kind of have that idea it's useful
for lots of purposes now working out you
know four thousand derivatives by hand
that's kind of a waste of time in my
view that's something getting an
intuition for how derivatives work and
how the chain rule works and so on
that's worthwhile and what it all means
that's worthwhile and and some of that
you get by actually doing the
experiments but actually using the
computer to do things you know I think
um I have to say just yesterday I got to
actually use some fancy calculus which I
haven't done in a long time and you know
it was sort of interesting because it
was a problem that um uh was was
actually amenable to you could actually
solve it
nail it get the answer closed form but
it's very complicated and you can only
get it using sort of calculus but by
hand not a chance way too complicated
but you know with Mathematica with
language it's like it just grinds all
the way through it and you get that
result and the result once you get it is
kind of interesting and you can kind of
understand some things from that result
but it's all about understanding things
from that result kind of the human
narrative around it not about the
Machinery of of getting there
so but I do think that sort of
mathematics is kind of a representation
of certain kinds of things that we can
understand so for example if you go to I
don't know an area like category Theory
fairly abstract area of mathematics
that's kind of a way of of
characterizing certain kinds of things
certain kinds of mathematical structures
certain kinds of structures in general
that we humans can talk about so to
speak and and so that stuff is pretty
interesting to learn I would say that
mathematics as a as a domain it's the
kind of the single largest kind of
intellectual artifact that's been
created by our civilization it's
probably only a million people who've
worked on the mathematics that we have
but it's you know relative to other
things in the world that's not that many
people but it's still a it's sort of a
coherent body of intellectual stuff
that's been developed and it's it's sort
of a it's an interesting thing to study
now you know another thing to say about
learning a field like mathematics is
there are you know their fields where
when you learn them you can apply what
you learned in lots of other places
physics for whatever reason has always
been the world's biggest export field
you know people learn physics they go do
quantitative Finance they do molecular
biology they do you know they do this or
that they do you know you find
physicists populating sort of all of the
places where kind of um structured
thinking gets done in the world
it is less true of mathematics and that
I would say is a is a a negative point
about some of the mathematics education
that goes on it should be the case in
the mathematics as well but it tends to
be the case that mathematics education
kind of makes itself so oriented towards
kind of the uh I would say that the sort
of the the the the I don't know the
mathematics race Source kind of
direction that it tends to detract from
using mathematics as something that can
be where you learn the methodology of
doing things in a structured abstract
way that can be applied elsewhere
so anyway I think I think the um the
answer is pursuing a math degree in the
age of AI yes but use the AI That's um
uh and that way you get to whatever the
AI can do that's you get to stand on the
shoulders of the AI so to speak and see
further if if you know what you're being
taught is just climbing the thing that
you know you could just immediately do
and move from language or something then
then you're being taught the wrong
things
um and that that's uh
and so my view on that
um
let's see bradyosts well different
Advanced AGI try to compete with each
other for resources
you know
I think one of the things as we talk
about AI governance and so on
one of the things I've been realizing
recently
is that I've been sort of thinking about
AI governance as there's one Ai and
you're kind of poking at it to tell it
what to do I don't think that's the
right point of view I think the right
point of view is there's a whole
ecosystem of AIS and can that whole
ecosystem like a society be stable
and I don't really know quite how to
think about that yet
um although I think it is it is similar
to saying you know if there was just one
human being so to speak and you wanted
them to do this or that thing it's very
undefined what they might do but by the
time they exist in this kind of
ecosystem it becomes more more possible
to Define what should happen and for
example in the case of AIS one of the
things that I was been thinking about is
this question of you know the problem
one of the problems of AI governance is
it's different from Human governance
because we humans kind of care about
what happens to us you know we have our
own skin in the game so to speak you
know we care if the world uh you know
decides that um uh you know we shouldn't
exist anymore or whatever we don't we
don't like that idea you know we we
intrinsically want to survive we
intrinsically want to you know lead a
happy life type thing or whatever well
not necessarily and that's not true for
everybody but we we we certainly most
people want to survive and um uh you
know we uh for different people maybe
they have different goals but but people
generally want to have a a life that
they consider satisfying so to speak
whereas for the AI
intrinsically it's just you know you
could say from the outside oh we can
just switch it off and and uh you know
it's not going to feel a thing kind of
thing now of course the same is true
with people we can't we only know by
extrapolation that if something bad
happens to another person out there that
it feels bad we only know that by
extrapolation from our own feelings we
don't know that as a matter of being
inside that person we only get to be
inside each of our own minds so to speak
so I think that the um but in the case
of AIS we don't sort of identify in that
way we don't say well we might say oh
poor computer you know it's having a
hard time type thing we we tend to
anthropomorphize that way but it only
goes a certain distance and we still
have the point of view that switching
off that AI is not something which has
the same kind of uh uh that doesn't
doesn't have the same characteristics as
switching off a human so to speak and
for the AI itself Its Behavior Uh will
not necessarily have any of the same
characteristics as humans have in their
sort of goal to survive now remember
that us humans got to where we are by
going through a few billion years of
evolution where the only way we got to
where we are is by having one the
struggle for life to get to the place
where we got to in biological evolution
so we needless to say we definitely have
that built-in kind of survival Instinct
because otherwise we simply wouldn't
exist in the struggle for Life over the
last couple of billion years but our AIS
haven't yet been given that survival
Instinct at least not in a systematic
way and we might say well actually it
could be a real problem to give our AIS
that survival Instinct because then
they're going to say we need to survive
and humans not surviving air don't worry
about that you know we just need to
survive because we have the survival
Instinct the advantage of an AI having a
survival Instinct is that then means
that it cares if there are things that
if it does if it does the wrong thing
and then the Society of AI says you know
we're going to sentence you to getting
switched off so to speak then the thing
is going to care about that and so it's
not going to want to do the wrong thing
but it's a it's a complicated setup and
my my own feeling is i i as I've
recently been thinking about this I
think the problem of sort of the the
Society of ai's problem and the
governance of a society of AIS may
actually be easier to solve than the one
AI governance problem in other words if
because it's kind of like when you talk
about the one AI governance problem and
you say that AI is going to get smarter
and smarter and smarter and it's going
to be able to be smarter than anything
that that could be you know Etc et
cetera et cetera by the way I think
that's a bad argument because the nature
of of what we know from theory of
computation and computational
irreducibility and so on there's never a
single path to smartness so to speak
there's never a single most successful
kind of uh organism computational
organism so to speak they're always an
infinite number of sort of
incommensurate kinds of uh kinds of
directions there
so it's um uh we're not um uh the um uh
you know I think that's
um
but but uh this question of of sort of
where you have the one Ai and you start
talking and it's very theological
actually it's very much you know angels
on heads of pins and things when you're
when you're talking about what can
happen as the as the one AI gets gets
more and more and more capable and you
kind of are always ending up talking
about sort of immovable barriers you
know uh you know on on
forces that are so strong you can't
resist them and so on irresistible
forces all those kinds of things it gets
it gets very difficult to Define I think
it may be is gets easier to Define when
you're talking about this whole sort of
society of AIS
um
let's see I Des is asking which is more
of an existential threat AI or quants
well I think the Quant AIS are an
interesting uh thing I mean in in you
know if the AIS can really detangle the
market
what will that mean if AIS could really
sort of uh sort of crush out any
Arbitrage opportunities in the market
is in you know in in financial markets
and so on what would that mean
uh one would think that that would mean
that markets will become more efficient
and that it would no longer be the case
that there's any thing where it's like
it will be the case that as soon as as
soon as I've got a thing that I want to
sell immediately that optimal sellers
will line up and they'll come and buy it
from me
um you know that's an interesting theory
of of things that that could be what
happens I mean as soon as I say hey I've
got 10 minutes of free time and I'm able
to figure out this or that thing
immediately kind of the AIS go into
action and they're kind of okay we can
sell that 10 minutes of time we can do
this and this and this and similarly all
the way through the economic markets and
financial markets and so on
um that could be what happens there
could also be bizarre instabilities that
occur which we don't understand very
well yet I mean it's kind of like the
natural world where there are things
where sort of collective things happen
occasionally there are tsunamis
occasionally there are hurricanes and
those are things that can develop and
they can be things that produce results
we don't like
and so similarly one might think okay if
it's AIS all the way down sort of
running every detail of financial
markets and so on one might have kind of
the the market storm that is like the
hurricane generated by the sort of
autonomous actions of the AIS and and
hard to for us to predict and bad for us
so to speak I don't know I think that
that's um
um uh you know that's a
uh that that's that's something that is
part of kind of the science of llms the
science of AIS something we don't
understand very well something I suspect
that there will be a partial theory of
that may even follow from some things
that we've done in our physics project
and so on kind of kind of a way of uh
collectively understanding things like
AIS where it may not matter that that AI
was programmed with all the pages from
the web it may just be that sort of
human knowledge has a certain generic
structure and just knowing that generic
structure is enough to predict or sort
of certain kinds of things about about
the behavior of aggregate AIS
um
let's see
I noticed that's asking here are we now
stuck with Kobo running most of the
world economy for the rest of all our
lives
you know it's a funny thing how
automation comes in a certain stage and
then uh you know to what extent it's
burnt in to what extent not when I was a
kid in England the currency was not
decimal Okay and like when I was
I don't know what it was probably the
the six-year-old me or something
five-year-old me or something like this
complaining why am I learning how to do
arithmetic with pound Shillings Pence
you know this is incredibly complicated
and why isn't currency just decimal
obviously you can make you know what you
care about is the amount of money not
how it's represented in pounds Shillings
Pence surely this can be decimal and
some teacher told me no no no you know
it's been this way for hundreds and
hundreds of years it'll be this way
forever
okay a couple of years later you know
it's announced in England you know the
decimalization of the currency happened
in 1970. it was very it was interesting
thing because it was when I was 10 years
old or so it was kind of like there were
a few days when the currency went from
being non-decimal to being decimal and
they were running on television for a
year beforehand they were running these
little shorts about trying to get people
intuition about how to deal with decimal
currency and so on and actually it went
very smoothly you know it didn't seem
like people were very confused at all it
was It was kind of kind of interesting
but why am I bringing this up I'm
bringing this up because 1970 was an
interesting time for decimalization
because if it had waited until 1973
calculators would have been a thing and
there would have been British
non-decimal currency calculators and I'm
not sure that there would have been the
same kind of push to decimalize the
currency because I think that the reason
people wanted to decimalize it is oh it
was hard to hard to work things out but
there would have come a time not many
years later when everybody would have
just had a calculator for doing it and
the value of simplifying it would have
been much lower and so similarly now you
know when you say well there's there's
Cobalt programs running out there okay
that may be the case and in the end
somewhere deep inside the machine it's
running some some crazy Cobalt thing but
it may be that by now we can build these
layers of wrappers on top of that that a
kind of Welcome language converts to
Cobalt type thing or whatever else it is
it doesn't really matter that there's
Cobalt underneath and I think that by
the way Cobble was not a bad design in
many ways better than many of the other
things that that came around those times
but in any case the um
I think this question of when do you
when do you wrap the the history up when
is it more convenient to wrap the
history in a modern coat and just keep
going versus to go back and re-engineer
what was there before and there are
plenty of cases where sort of this
grandfathering of existing technology is
worthwhile and I wouldn't be surprised
if some of what happens uh it has
happened already you know it's like okay
you can go and you can re-architect all
computers you can give them different
instruction sets and you go and build
all the everything differently for those
different instruction sets and that has
happened happens in the transition from
the 808x86 architecture to things like
the arm architecture and so on although
that Dynamic is a complicated economic
story that wasn't quite as you know just
going up to better technology so to
speak it was a different different set
of issues but um the uh you know I think
that this question of when do you wrap
the layers of the old versus when do you
kind of pull those all out and start
from scratch it's kind of like when you
when cities you know ancient cities used
to be like built one layer on top of
another I suspect modern cities it's
much more like let's just you know uh
demolish that building and we're going
to start again from scratch in that
place it's often rather expensive to
start from scratch and it's easier to
the incremental build out you know if we
look at operating systems that exist
today you know I think the Microsoft
operating system stack is is a is a
progressive build type stack Apple for
example had this one discontinuity when
Apple bought next and they basically
just threw away their existing operating
system and started again I suppose
they've partly done that even again with
iOS although that's still a bit of a
messy story
um
let's see
uh
some question here about Maxwell's demon
and uh how does it deal with the second
order of thermodynamics and so on
so I just wrote this book about the
second order of thermodynamics and I
which is the result of me having thought
about that topic for uh 50 years
actually
um
Maxwell's demon let me explain what it
is for people who don't know so
normally when when you have gas
molecules for example bouncing around in
a box even though they may start in an
orderly pattern after not very long the
gas molecules will be bouncing around in
a kind of random pattern and that
phenomenon is the essence of the second
orthodynamics that you go from sort of a
simple initial condition to apparent
Randomness I think the origin of that is
primarily computational irreducibility
that you're effectively encrypting the
initial conditions that you have they do
you could still in principle reconstruct
them but it takes too much computational
effort for one to do that when one makes
realistic measurements and a measurement
might be you know what's the overall
pressure of the gas it's just how much
what's the aggregate of all these gas
molecules pushing on a piston not
where's every individual gas molecule
let's do a complicated computation so
the idea of Maxwell's demon is old James
Clark Maxwell had this idea of um this
uh Little Creature who would have a
little trap door and um uh which would
which would kind of and the demon would
be looking at every molecule that comes
by and if the molecule is let's say
going fast would let it through the Trap
Brewer if it's going more slowly it
would not let it through the trap door
and that would cause the gas to do very
non-random things you know Maxwell's
original version I think actually Kelvin
had a version of this in which they
talked about uh a little demons with
miniature cricket bats because they were
British
um you know batting away the molecules
and so on but any case the idea is this
sort of microscopic thing that is in a
sense figuring out enough about the gas
that it can decide what to do rather
than just sort of in the aggregate uh
you know having something which puts the
gas in a container or whatever else
the story of Maxwell's demons is people
have had all these arguments oh you
can't make a Maxwell's demon because the
demon would have to have a certain
memory that gets erased the demon would
have to use a flashlight that takes a
certain amount of the the expense a
certain amount of entropy et cetera et
cetera et cetera I think all of these
arguments just aren't really right that
the ultimate story is if the demon can
sort of do enough computation the demon
can decode the gas but in practice we
don't get to do enough computation to be
able to decode the gas that's just a
feature of us as Observers
so what happens you know these days sort
of every issue of the fancy physics
journals practically seems to have an
article about another Maxwell's
demon-like thing
what's going on in these cases well
what's going on is that for small enough
numbers of molecules and sophisticated
enough measuring devices and
computations being done on the
measurements they make you can make
Maxwell's demons little tiny ones that
will deal with untangling what happens
with 20 gas molecules or something
untangling what happens with a few more
gas molecules it's a thing which is a
matter of sort of when we get to when we
increase the the the sophistication of
our technology then we get to untangle
more about what's happening do more
computation effectively be a better
Maxwell's demon you know an interesting
thing is people often talk about as a
result of singular thermodynamics this
idea of the heat death of the universe
that eventually every detail of what's
happening in the universe it'll all just
be a random gas and thermal equilibrium
with molecules randomly bouncing around
and they say that's a that's a really
bad outcome there's nothing left in the
universe at that point it's all boring
from then on out but of course you have
to realize that all those detailed gas
molecules they are our future and
everything about us is eventually
encoded in the detailed motions of those
gas molecules a trillion years in the
future or whatever now you know at that
point we can have a very sophisticated
Maxwell demon-like thing that
effectively is saying oh look I noticed
that gas molecule here and there and the
other and that's a sign of something
very interesting and I really care about
that and that's the the sort of the
great art of that future civilization or
whatever is this particular pattern of
gas molecules so in a sense the the the
size of the the successor Maxwell's
demon seems to increase with sort of the
the sophistication of our civilization
and at some point it's kind of like we
get to operate on a molecular scale by
the way I think there are many processes
in biology where we are orchestrating
the motion of molecule skills in ways
that for practical purposes is is sort
of a Maxwell's demon-like behavior and I
think that that people will say oh but
but there's another measure of entropy
etc etc it's not really the point the
point is when when if you're asking does
the system go from a state that is
simple to a state that looks random the
answer May simply be no and that's the
thing that uh and and that happens
because of the fact that you're you're
sort of putting in enough computational
effort to be able to make that make that
inversion I'm kind of compressing a lot
of things into into a short space here
but perhaps that will be useful um uh
that was asked by the way by by plotnik
um who asks another question here
um
about Stanislaus Lems similar
technological eye
um was written in the I guess late 50s I
think late 1950s
uh
you know
I have
read pieces of of lem's work and every
time I read it I think this is really
very good very interesting and um you
know unsurprisingly forward-looking so
to speak
and um I think it's interesting my
impression is
that in a sense stanislam was sort of an
abstract thinker of some kind
and that a lot of what he was saying was
there is this thing where there are sort
of this kind of mushy way of thinking
about it in the world one day this will
be cleaned up made more abstract made
more able to be sort of modularly done
and I think that's sort of a pattern in
what he said and that's a pattern in
what has happened technologically
and I think you're asking a question
what what thoughts do I have on the sort
of predictive power and limitations of
technological forecasting
you know I have a feeling often it is
the case it's easier to know what will
happen than when it will happen I think
one could be wrong by 100 years and when
things can happen or even more than that
and but to know that certain kinds of
things which are kind of in in many
cases to know certain kinds of things
that aren't a messy today will
eventually be abstractly factored and be
things that can be done or things where
it is possible to do it but it's super
expensive that will be something where
we can know it will eventually be sort
of readily possible to do then there are
other things which are just outright
surprises where just nobody really
thought about doing that before and it
um
it was something that um uh really was a
way of making use of the natural world
or the abstract world
to often achieve a human purpose that we
didn't necessarily identify as a human
purpose before now there are some like
social media for example where we might
say that came out of nowhere but it
really didn't because social social
interactions existed have existed
throughout the history of our species
just the Dynamics of whether it's on the
web or whether it's in the Village
Square maybe is not as important as the
fact that there is that drive to have
those social interactions
now I think that um uh
you know another thing that can be
difficult is to know a given thing where
there is a stub of activity you know the
fax machine first you know the first
kind of sort of image transmitter by
telegraph was early 1800s but it took
until the 1970s late 1970s
uh even
yeah even early 1980s before fax
machines which have now gone obsolete
again but before they achieved you know
sort of the the economic Dynamics to
become widespread uh similarly you know
helicopters versus
quadcopter drones and things you know
helicopters existed since um
um the uh oh gosh I mean in um the 40s
there were sort of early helicopters and
so on and uh but but they didn't really
take off in a white literal sense
um but no they were taking off just fine
in the literal sense but they didn't
really become a big thing and now sort
of drones have become a thing with
different economic Dynamics and so on so
that stuff tends to be rather hard to
predict when's it going to happen you
know you can be wrong by many
generations
and rather easy to be wrong by many
generations I was mentioning before the
mistake I made about flat screen
televisions where the thing I didn't
figure out is the yield has to be
basically a hundred percent of pixels
otherwise you can't use the flat screen
television because you've got this nasty
place where nothing changes in the image
and in some particular place
so um you know that that's uh
I have to say now now in terms of
shorter term kinds of things
and you know is blockchain going to make
it or is virtual reality finally going
to make it this time or is uh some kind
of uh
um you know Medical Technology going to
make it or not there are certainly
heuristics one can apply and that their
cases where uh I don't know I've been
trying to watch these kinds of things
and paying attention to things that I
didn't didn't bet on over the last 50
years or so and there definitely are
patterns that one can see of things
where for me it's anytime it's a mystery
technology where I profoundly don't
understand how it works it's uh it's
usually it's not going to go as far as
people think it's going to go type thing
you know for example for llms you know I
got a bit confident about them after I
thought I actually began to understand
kind of the semantic grammar of language
that llms discover and sort of what is
the meta description of how they work
rather than just it's magic be happy
type thing
so let's see
uh
Paul is commenting well their ideas to
put 10 months in a year yeah I think
wasn't there in the um uh the French
Revolutionary calendar right had 10 day
weeks I think
um people didn't like it very much you
know it's funny because there are these
things which I don't know whether the
seven day week is a a thing that just
we've gotten so used to over the course
of the of several Millennia that it's
just that's what feels right but whether
there really is something about sort of
the the ergonomics of us humans that
makes that be the right kind of thing I
mean I think that's um uh you know
you've got to remember that there are
features of us humans that have been
kind of the same for at least 50 000
years or something that are uh you know
that will determine things where you
could say well yes in principle we could
have some you know swirling visual thing
where you're picking up information from
this and that and the other it's like
well yes in principle you could do that
but us humans just our brains don't work
fast enough our eyes don't work uh with
enough resolution Etc et cetera et
cetera
um
let's see
uh
a bunch of quite scientifically
technical questions here which I think I
should answer in different live stream
um
yeah
lotra asks
um Can AI be used to create better
prompts or is that kind of human
consciousness dependent
I think
that if you can Define what you want
then you can potentially ask the AI to
give it to you better
but if you can't Define what you want
and just say make a better prompt
that's one of these untethered kinds of
things where it's like well humans
you've got to tell me what you want
uh I think one of the things that's sort
of interesting right now is when you ask
an AI how do you put in a prompt
something which will stop the AI from
doing such and such a thing I don't
think it does great at answering that
but I can imagine it being able to do
that I can imagine it being able to say
given this problem with this prompt you
know how come you say you know I gave
you a prompt that said make a two
sentence summary and you gave me a
fourth sentence summary how come what
should I have done differently in the
prompt to get me a two sentence summary
I don't think you'll get 100 success
with that but I think it's a kind of
thing where you could potentially ask
the AI to quote improve itself to Hue
more closely to the thing that you
wanted it to do
um but I think that when it comes to uh
sort of just writing quotes better
prompt without a definition of what
better means I think that's something
that isn't going to work now you could
say write a prompt that will make us
humans happier that's possible that
might be a thing I I don't think the
results will be all that good as a
practical matter but that's something
one could imagine doing I mean it is
rather a terrible thought that you know
the the L alums and so on they are
learning from sort of the average of
humanity they are learning from the
whole statistics of what all of us have
put on the web they're sort of learning
the average of what we put out there and
in a sense you know one talks about kind
of reversion to the mean of things
there's uh there's kind of a um a thing
where
where one can say you know if what's
going to happen in the world is it's all
llms it's like okay then we're reverting
everything to the mean it's kind of like
we're making everything as banal as the
average of all possible uh kinds of
things that we humans have put on the
web so that's a that's kind of a not not
great thing and then we say well okay
let's let the alarm make some spiky
things that go out in different funky
directions but then we're asking well
which funky directions do you want to go
out in and that's something which is
really a human kind of question to
answer what that's a question of what we
choose to want to do it's a very
difficult question to answer because you
know one set of people may say that's a
great direction to go in other people
said people may say that's a deeply
immoral direction to go in well that's
an ethically terrible direction to go in
you know I think one of the things that
I've sort of understood a little bit I I
feel like I'm not I haven't sort of
climbed this hill properly yet but about
thinking about ethics for example you
know I'm used to thinking about science
where you can do things where in the end
you get a clean answer because you have
been able to define a sort of very
precise scientific experiment where all
of the confounding factors have been
sort of pushed away you've got this sort
of perfect experiment where you only
care about the things in the Box you
don't care about anything outside the
box it is my impression that in ethics
that's fundamentally not true that
ethics is in a sense a story of the
whole Human Experience the whole
societal experience it's not a thing
where you can say I'm going to do Ethics
in this box ignoring everything else
ethics is a societal question and
Society is necessarily sort of in if we
were thinking about in terms of
thermodynamics maybe it's a bit of a
physics joke it would be to say it's
like a heat bath it's like the thing
where you've got all those molecules
bouncing around and that's what's
connecting with your with your object
not the object all on its own that
that's that ethics is sort of
fundamentally assist societal are not
separatable from you know not doable as
a kind of an independent sort of uh
precisely defined experiment with no
other confounding factors
uh all right I think I need to uh wrap
up just a moment here is there anything
I can look at here that is easy to talk
about
you guys give me all sorts of things
that are wonderfully not easy to talk
about which is great
um
uh
well
Tess is commenting which will history
just judges the biggest letdown 2023's
AI Mania VR is the inevitable in their
future uh
or let's see the film 2001 the the
artificial intelligence
um uh
movie from 2001 the biggest letdown the
biggest we thought it was going to
happen but it didn't
um
an interesting question
you know whenever there's a new
technology
and LMS are a good example
there's a period of time you know
elements were actually very surprising
because llam's nobody expected the level
of in your face kind of look it can do
this now and it wasn't possible before
that actually happened
now perhaps that overshoots and
certainly once saw lots of people saying
oh ai's just going to take over
everything and Etc et cetera et cetera
and then it then it overshoots then it
comes back and people say oh no it was a
bit oversold and then eventually it
comes to the level it should be at my
own opinion is LMS are actually
important for lots of things and
represent this kind of new level of
linguistic user interface that's really
very useful for many many many purposes
and they are a real technology that's
here to stay and not just kind of a a
thing that was a uh uh you know that
um uh that one will think was relevant I
mean that there are you know I just
remember all these things in the
technology industry for example there
are these things where people say it's
going to be amazing it's going to be you
know and and it turns into I don't know
why but for some reason I remember push
technology for which is a kind of a
simple idea but but um you know I that
one comes to mind where that was just
going to be you know there were
companies that was going to take over
everything it was going to be whatever
it's like yeah it eventually becomes
part of the infrastructure that that's a
thing that happens with websites and and
web servers and browsers and things like
this and it's not the the be-all and end
all of the world it's just a thing that
knits itself into the kind of
infrastructure of how things work and
that will happen to some extent with
other Lambs although there are some
things that I think will be
substantially enabled by that that
weren't possible before just as I don't
know with let's say bitmap displays on
computers
um there were things that got enabled
with that or Laser Printers for high
resolution printing there were things
that got enabled by that that were in a
sense qualitatively different from what
it existed before but it's an
interesting question what will be the um
um you know I I have to say although I
I'm a great Optimist as you can tell
from these live streams I'm also a
practical person and sometimes a bit of
a cynic when I see kind of you know
these things where it's like this is
going to be amazing kind of thing and
it's like I I I've seen this stuff for
half a century now and uh I kind of
pride myself on being able to call a lot
of those uh you know correctly I roll on
on many of those kinds of things and uh
uh you know AI is going to be able to
solve this AI is going to be able to
solve that well no it's not
um you know AI is going to uh do this or
that I do notice there's a question here
about um uh there's a lot of interesting
questions all right you go you're gonna
let me go because I've got to go back to
my day job otherwise uh I can't go on
having having my hobby here but but um
um the uh
uh there's a question from platin
account I just make one comment on this
about AI tutors replacing human tutors
in the next few years I think AI tutors
will be very worthwhile I think it's
very interesting I think that I think
that there is a human to human
persuasion aspect that might be able to
be that that really is still a thing
that's important humans react to humans
that's still a thing my guess is that
like so many other kinds of automation
it's kind of like there's a layer of
automation of tutoring that will become
possible let me give you an example in
wolf malpha with our show steps
capabilities there are things where in
the past before 10 years ago uh what is
it no gosh it's 2009 the 13 years ago 14
years ago
um before that time if you wanted to
know how to do that math problem
chemistry problem physics Problem
whatever it is use work now for four if
you wanted to know how to do that step
by step the only way to find out was
kind of go ask somebody now you don't
have to do that anymore you can just use
Wolfmother and so that allowed that sort
of opened up a lot of kind of things
that were did require human tutoring
could now be to automatically be done
automatically I think the same will
happen again with llms I think it's
really nice with llms that you get to do
things like cost questions in a certain
framework in a certain you know if the
kid only cares about uh gardening for
example you get to uh to cast sort of
every math word problem as a gardening
problem type thing or every chemistry
problem is something related to
gardening or whatever else it is and
that I think may be very helpful in
terms of of Engagement uh you know
helping engagement and so on but I think
you know I think a lot of important
things will happen with llm tutoring
we're working on that quite a bit I
would say that I don't know for sure I
you know this is one of these things
about technology prediction right it's
you know because I'm actually in the in
the in the business of running a
technology company that tries to do
things that uh kind of push the the
frontier of what's possible things like
wolfen Alpha for example I didn't know
when we started building wolf Alpha in
2005 or 2004 and whatever it was I
didn't know it was possible I didn't
know that was doable in this generation
in the century even it was a bet that I
made that it was going to be possible
and it turns out it worked and that is
you know insofar as one is doing
technology prediction for me it's been
important in my life that I can do a
technology prediction well enough but I
don't make horrible bets on products
that are impossible and I have to say
I've done I touch wood Pat myself on the
back whatever you know mostly I've done
a really good job at that of not of of
defining things which are certainly very
difficult they look impossible at the
beginning but they don't turn out to be
impossible you know things like uh uh
physics project for example might have
been just outright impossible
it went much better than I expected it
to go much much better but nevertheless
I I knew it was not just outright
impossible I thought it was not just
outright impossible and that's why I
pursued it and and so similarly here
with things like llm tutoring I'm pretty
sure it's going to work and that's why
we're going to pursue it I don't think
it's trivial to get it to work I think
there are many bumps in the road I think
there are many many cases just like with
wolf malphar there are many things that
could have been done in the building
evolved from alpha that would have led
to failure and and to actually get it to
the point where you've navigated it
through to to make the thing that
actually works is not trivial and with
llm tutoring it's absolutely the same
way I can already see that there are
many many bumps in the road that you
have to kind of avoid uh correctly or
you end up with something which just is
is either useless embarrassing
horrifying or other kinds of things and
hopefully we'll be able to do that I'm
pretty confident we will and I don't
know exactly how far it will go but
that's going to be interesting to see
all right well thank you all very much
for for
um joining me and uh a lot of
interesting questions and I see um
uh more that I look forward to being
able to address
um another time
so thanks a lot and bye for now